ladies and gentlemen welcome into the
studio you see buddy Jim Breuer is here
what's going on man how are you good
yeah he's always got something he
doesn't rest well he's always there's
always something going on with numb good
oh you don't need this in your life do
you three kids no it's not the one
you're scared of yeah I mean when you
get sickness in your house I mean that
probably just stagnates for a month it's
like being on a small bus or someone's
going down yes and goes down here
everyone gets sick right yeah let me
look at you you're always in shape I
feel I feel okay I'm not in good shape
as I was six months ago but I'm okay all
right what's crumbling what's crumbling
where where's your weakness where's the
fans outcome yeah by the way it's not
it's not crumbling it's expanding I got
a fatso I can't find my little fatso
kids I mean a part of me is like yeah I
just I'm kind of done fighting it like
this is all staring at now like you
gotta figure out where it's like I'm in
much better shape than I I'm in decent
shape
yeah I'm still enjoying I don't have to
go right right I'm gonna get taking
aspirin every day yet there's no
diabetes shot you don't have to get
insulin shots no you know cluster a
little high or I'll live with that yeah
a little high little high cares
cholesterol take it easy relax enjoy
your cholesterol you know what I mean
yeah but yeah I mean the fact that you
could go because when you're in like
shape that's so good that you're not
really supposed to be in that good of
shape yeah I never in that shape every
window you know streak you're on a hot
streak we have a really thin though like
I was really really thin that's what I
mean like you're not supposed to be that
skinny and when you're that skinny and
you want to stay that skinny you can
never eat or do anything regularly yeah
yeah that's kicks your ass after a while
yeah
finally [ __ ] apples gonna eat and and
and pretend like oh I have I have a
treat what Apple's a sweet drag yeah
it's really good and if you mix just a
quarter of a banana it's not too much
sugar here ooh I did recently I took
bananas and I cut him up and I put him
in a freezer and I mushed him up and
then I [ __ ] I poured put like a
little light cinnamon on them and a
teeny bit of cooking chocolate and I
made myself a treat that I was sick of
in three bites is this spiked candy bar
banana [ __ ] treat just buy candy I just
thought it would be cool I was in the
supermarket you just made it up
yep it's not a bad idea there's a mushed
up bananas through cinnamon and cooking
I've heard like an ice cream you can
make it there's something else I like
like like unsweetened coconut shavings
yeah they get boring nothing I did all
this you tried it all it's over yeah
it's over cuz people who are doing it
will tell you no I mean you really don't
miss it once you get used to the coconut
shavings it's just as good as a snake
person as a heroine I have a friend and
he had no sugar no meat uh-huh he was
paying the balls to go to dinner with em
hmm and everything had to be specific he
had a stroke oh my god that's stroke not
even 50
he's probably gained at least hundred
he's just said I don't give a [ __ ] he
just eats he eats everything this big
got piss ranks he got past it got angry
he took care of himself
yeah he's raging as the fatso machine he
don't care right eats meat all the time
now was it what what gave him the stroke
does that have anything to do would it
have been worse if even you didn't meet
her no probably probably there's there's
something wrong with his thyroid with
the veins and they isn't that weird one
can give you stroke every day there's
always something that's scares me more
than a heart attack as I'm sure you have
your body just [ __ ] quits and now
it's always something it's a CAD careful
you know don't wear a hat too tight
strokes yeah I know two people just went
done fried eggs gotta hear strokes are
they finished
yeah fifty well yeah he [ __ ] up your
friend Rosie because now he's done it's
out of here six feet under who died oh
wow yeah man were that age
oh yeah a lot of more dropping dead yes
absolutely that's that aah Jesus yeah
and you don't I mean it's kind of
unavoidable it's like it's like the list
of foods that cause cancer they're like
potato chips overcooked and undercooked
and semi cooked meat like I mean it's
it's everything that you could eat
paranoid I wasn't gonna eat a banana and
I don't know the bananas the last four
or five years five feet long yeah
when did that that's not normal now it's
also now I'm afraid to eat it those are
people you can eat as healthy as you
want the food is so [ __ ] up crash I
went to I went to Europe the banana
that's a normal-looking bananas oh you
guys got the old school banana normally
we come here two bananas four feet long
it's seven inches thick perfectly yellow
yeah Brown for three weeks
my grandmother usually bananas out
overnight because she liked to eat them
brown they were easier to motion mushy
bananas yeah yeah terrible palette the
old bag so uh well you're going back on
tour I've never done a tour like this
I I did the last time I really went on
tour was a gym and then all right for
that it's like 2003 Wow
well how are you miss comedians always
we always you get it you get some offers
you get date your agent goes oh yeah
Seattle wants to have you there for X
amount of dollars and then also Vera's
onna so maybe we can tie these together
but we never really called it tour right
it's just a handful of dates this is uh
like a tour going out two weeks come
home for a week come back out for you to
Boston
no I got that kind of cash that kind of
cash I make it I'm not making that money
yeah I've done less dates it's like I
don't mind it cuz I started to stop for
30 years 29 years I just constant and
now looks like a little slowed down
well you know and you get a radio gig
yeah this is everyday this is everyday
you don't need and you don't have yeah
you're I have no kids no real no spouse
of them and your gate and tween we know
where we're at
yeah I know where we're at that's true I
don't you know there's a little part of
us I shouldn't speak for you there's a
little part of us it's like yeah you
know why ain't I on the cover of you
know not happening it's done dari Jim
Norton the shot happening ships are gone
[Laughter]
anticipated it's fine right this is good
things are good things are real good and
that's fine yeah right that's what you
want yeah this should be good
going back to Sarge people going back to
day jobs after a certain a that's scary
guys who like doing it for 15 18 years
and they stop and they start [ __ ] I
think I want to start running a comedy
club you know it's you know it's it
sells really well and I can still MC
Mexico right Alka polka but it's
seasonal tourists a lot of tourists why
don't we get the cruise boat guys and
there's nothing wrong with that they
just go no [ __ ] scares me you knit you
need that that scares me right because
it's not the onstage part of this is not
what you didn't work out right you got
to figure out you're trying to stay in
the industry which you should I love
that they're trying to stay in the
industry but it reminds you that you're
lucky that you don't have to figure out
how to just stay in the industry right
right you're there yeah yeah
broadcasting makes you feel like at
least you're doing something yes this is
something big it's the big deal you know
I'm saying like you feel like you're
working you don't think you're stag eh
do you feel any different having slowed
down slightly with your dates because so
for so long you're you're manic about
the fact that you had to work all the
time always on the road always working
working working you're at like the first
time in your life that you slow down
even slight
you're still working all the time yeah
yeah but even taking some moments some
weekend time not working every single
night I love it do you feel any
different in your material and your
process now it takes me a few minutes
longer to get to remember the act late
like I like I'll have to go like into my
first set usually but I'm doing a
weekend like by the second show I know
the whole the thing is like more
comfortable in a wheel yeah but my last
two shows have been the best shows I've
had in a couple years
you probably enjoyed a little bit more
than you're not yeah doing it every
single pressure and pressure
yes Jimbo Wright's going in there he's
laser beam how was it do Metallica do I
think you every time I see them how
[ __ ] crazy you go up into an hour in
front of that crowd one hour it would it
would let me this will make you feel
better I was more of a fluff guy meaning
they wanted me to I didn't know what I
was walking into I'm reaching out to you
and it's a bunch of cuz I don't know
it's funny I didn't know what I was
walking into they wanted an hour and a
half of of some type of entertainment
while people were cut they wanted to get
people in sure so the first half hour
when you walked in I got all these old
videos and pictures so when you sit down
oh wow there's cliff I've never seen
that picture a cliff or a video than be
an interview I never saw that so just
loose I was on the couch then I had a
guy go up play songs where you requested
hey you guys got a song with 80% I
plugged in my plate Unchained play
Motorhead yeah play this one play that
one then I would go up at 7:00 7:30 was
it how long was the showman happening by
that point an hour an hour okay 7:30 I
go up I would usually stay onstage to
about 8 10 after 8:00
but I realized by the second let by
about the third fourth show this isn't a
stand-up show right there
allowed i'm-a-comin synagogue what the
yeah who's this guy ties from the radio
yeah
was this guy doing yeah she's doing a
stories what is he doing so to get
through that and then I realized after a
while I can't I don't have to be
understate well I have to be honest a
I'm going the crowd and that was
actually more effective once I started
going in the crowd hunting people down
pointing people out getting the oldest
guy in the arena
get me youngest kid in arena and [ __ ]
like that and would bring the whole I'm
like where's the oldest guy and then I'd
have sections gone became like a variety
show so yeah I mean they all and now
they're all my side I don't we find this
guy then I I would take a live camera
and I'd go backstage look for the band a
lot of times I found Lars never Jane's
was never walking the halls and then I
would do a game show how did they feel
about the camera be backstage Lars loves
it he does loves it the other guys are
kind of like yeah man Laurens got such a
bad reputation from that Napster thing
it's funny was right thousand percent
everybody just thought he's the narc of
the group he's the no fun guy he's just
the opposite he's actually the fun he
not only is he not a Z the fungi he goes
out of his way to please fans I've never
seen anyone on a level like him just go
out of the way he's always asked me is
like what the there was one part of the
tour where I started knowing all these
Metallica fans and they would they were
called the black ticket holders so they
had tickets to every single show and
they travel with the band yes I run the
band they're from all over the world
yeah and every night they start
gathering with me and we had bang like
like jackasses by the soundboard and
they would rent out homes I Airbnb and
then I started going there the hangout
these guys went so well and Lars at one
point was like when what time you doing
this thing with the guys and are you
really thinking about going area
you can you know if I can work it out
tomorrow deal of to go so he loves doing
stuff how many people were in the area
me oh my god like 20 something so can
you imagine be in that neighborhood and
you see about 20 I am with it
I'm not kidding there were Nicaragua
Mexican Swedish Denmark American they
were four Canadian from all old Mexican
they were all over the place all in this
one put guys a long hair some people
long hair everywhere black everyone had
black black shirts but just Metallica
like reach out to them like is there
some kind of no you guys are the
hardcore is we're gonna open these
tickets up to you if you want one for
every show here you can buy him you know
Metallica gives you the opportunities
it's called the black there's only so
many got you black tickets and the
tickets come down like 18 bucks a show
because you buy all of them if you could
you buy all of them yeah and then they
travel eight the way they all say it is
you know the way we get to travel the
world in the country and and see and
with a man and it becomes more about yes
it becomes the concert and band but then
it becomes that they've they created
their own little family sure and they
still hang out and they still they show
up tall my shows it's insane amazing
wait what are they doing largely they
didn't know he was coming no and I
wouldn't tell them that yeah I wouldn't
tell them that but he want and then when
weird when I was done he called me the
next day he's like can you tell me if
you're gonna do that again oh he didn't
go no he didn't go he couldn't go
he was definitely thinking of it hey I
want dad we were talked about this
before I'm not even thinking that you
were coming yet I forgot that you know
these guys kirk hammett house have you
been to it i have it the hawaii one
we're talking about his father [ __ ] he
did a great book on that study no
pictures of all that stuff it was really
good i I'm pretty I know he was in
Hawaii for a while and then he left
Hawaii I think he went back I've talked
with in the least you know yeah I want
to hang out with him more
but you
she seems more eats a lot of my level
he's a pretty shy guy right no it's not
shy he's just kind of is she's very no
no it's just kind of his own little
evident keeps to himself
did you like the president he wants a
piece right everybody Kirk years and
years and years and years ago over 20
years ago at least
you introduced me to those guys in 97
Jim was on SNL that's how long he knows
more time they do different shows they
were at the tour they have one like this
is the show Lea they change five songs a
show there's five songs that they rotate
throughout the show I guess the Four
Horseman is one of that they don't do
that every show I think when I saw him I
didn't know they didn't they didn't do
that one but there was um one thing that
I thought was good I love the new album
and they started playing here comes
revenge which I think that song should
be on the radio and I think that song
should be like every ballpark when your
team is losing and then you're coming
with a rally this song is insane but
sure they just had the five that they
trade off in between yeah right so
memory remains see what where's this one
four horsemen four horsemen is a bit
harvester sorrow
wait did you go to Russia no I only do
the States are you okay
there was one point where Lars calls me
in three three nights before the show
ends before the US tour ends and he goes
do you think that this could work in a
stadium say like Belgium okay and I went
well you know my ego and my selfishness
would would say I'll find a way but I
don't do you think I do you think you
need a band in a place like that
absolutely did you can't have celiac
talking not only that half them nobody
knows you at least playing this
States I'm gonna say 10% you're hoping
for the 10 I'll say 5 to 10% one knew
the name like Jim Breuer yeah yeah isn't
that the guy and then maybe 3 to 5% like
[ __ ] Jim Breuer during do follow me
but they're also not even comedy fans
necessarily like Metallica fans music
fans and in an arena I have a lot of
confidence because I can go to you and I
will and I don't have a problem I had I
had all the confidence where I was not
scared but what a stadium in another El
Djem in Belgium so where's my no this is
not gonna happen
how many just English anyway it's it's
end on a high which is what I did
and um you know then they head to Europe
if I will tell you this I would retire
to do that gig the rest of my life you
would a hundred person would just
because it's a dream cake it was the
greatest gig I ever had in my life it
was how many shows 3435 over six month
period so they go out every - every
month I do like two weeks something like
that and every other day it was to sit
with you know you were on a road I don't
know if you go out with a crew a lot of
times is you and what is it's depressing
yeah it's depressing
shirred I had no problem getting up at
11:30 getting on the tour bus with all
the techs and they're telling stories
about whatever this guy used to work for
ac/dc this guy let's then they're
talking about names where you going yeah
and then you can you coffee and you're
in the arena noon now I can go walk
around the I can walk wherever I want
I don't have to do any seven but I like
a Turing's at noon and I'm talking to
the lighting guy and a sound person and
the [ __ ] then you finished at the end
the night you're on the tour bus you
want to drink this you want to eat
I think and I'm watching the concert I
was I was 18 years old after my stick
after I was done it took it took a
couple times where I finally just went I
don't give it too I don't care is a
videotaping I'm done with the trying to
put on a persona when I'm alone I go
apeshit
yeah when no one's home I go apeshit a
lot of this music apeshit so when they
were done my favorite part was it was
one night I'm hanging out by the
soundboard as a little Asian guy and
he's banging his head and one of the
songs I went up to him and we started in
each other's faces and we went for four
songs and then a little crowd gathered
and then this became a thing every
single night we did about three I could
I couldn't go more than three songs I
was exhausted but it became if certain
songs were play every one the back would
strike at brower and I'd come out and we
do no remorse no regret or we do the
whatever song it was Unforgiven for sure
I know it sounds for me it's like I'm
Forrest Gump that you yeah I'm getting
paid to do this and hang out and watch
the Metallica yeah hang out after why
what it's are you a believer I mean I
just think it's so great that you're
able to just maintain that fandom and
not let you like your ego creep in and
be like well you know I do a show two
people should be coming out to see my
show it's like no like what would you do
if you were a kid going like you can go
on tour with Metallica and just hang out
with no one's there come and said no one
goes wait a minute
Brewers Metallica's going on now bro no
one's doing but you figured out a way to
make it work the ask is that you know
again did you have any shows that were
bad like when you were doing stand-up
would any of them like rough what were
they all good the all I could honestly
say the only trouble is the very first
one because
they said they insisted they wanted me
onstage until they went on and there
their reason was they're big fans and
they want their fans that Know Who I am
very flattered when he going up tonight
8:30 is that a hundred percent because
I've seen you million times oh yeah 8:30
okay right before they go away it took
the production minute what time that
8:30 imagine everyone's there it's the
first night nervous I got local football
stars going up I got a game show and all
this she had a planned every 15 you did
yeah I only talked for 15 minutes at
9:00 then it had game shows and the
football guy like that it yeah they
liked it they liked it it kept things
moving and then it changed dramatically
but in right within a couple weeks a 20
I go backstage
are we 8:30 8:30 I go up when James
comes out I want to make sure I tell
them which side to start off with which
which sections the bed you know do that
whole sure these guys I don't know I
think they're louder they'll always fall
for that every time they'll never not
fall for it
okay everyone from this side over and
8:30 and I go God thank you guys all
right left and the stage managed like oh
no they're not ready so [ __ ] because she
get a couple more two more minutes
went up I'm there another seven oh I'm
sorry we're gonna do this one more time
I do it again as about as almost 8:40
now okay they're not ready Wow
now they did another term getting a lot
of bottom jaw sticking out fingers
[Music]
[Laughter]
they've turned our date they were not
happy it was dry so that we couldn't
serve booze into place so all their
buzzes are disappearing and they didn't
come out - almost seven minutes to nine
and they there's it was that was not fun
23 rough minutes I was brutal so after
that night I said okay next show where
are they before they come out oh they're
in the tune-up room so they go and they
jam for 40 minutes they're really the
jammin rehearse every single [ __ ]
minute yeah how much is that every
single show every single show 40 minutes
and then I asked is James like do you
guys see him with any he put a good way
when he's you know Jim we all got lives
I don't know who's I don't know whose
life is going on with their wife and
kids what this one's going on what what
dramas going on each world and none of
us really see each other together until
before we go on stage I want to sit in a
room where like this is the only time
where Metallica and now nothing
interferes and then when we're ready
that's when we'll go out so nobody comes
in that room oh but he's gonna have you
been in there no the only two and that's
nothing I went in the first night cuz I
brought a fan to come watch and then
after that it was I had like yet James I
did that I can't we can't have anyone in
here only because we feel like we have
to perform and I just this is our zone
time sure oh yeah that makes sense
totally get it so the only ones in there
are recording and the text or whatever
tech is in there so [ __ ] are talking
about just talking about but then let
that show and what you did the next
night oh look at nice so that in the
second night
okay okay I'm standing outside the tuna
room and when all them are out that's
when I go back on stage and that's what
I did after their like know how long
they've been in there
Oh they've been in there 15 minutes oh
good I got time to go out and do a quick
game show see if someone get booed off
the stage which was awesome missing
questions oh yeah oh my god is the
greatest good older and I bring them up
and we test them they couldn't get any
answers the whole Krupp or they win I
would bring them backstage and then when
metallic is ready to come out and they
do their circle whatever I would bring
them and stand and let them watch that
oh that's amazing
that's a good prize yeah it's so funny
how much goes into like a show like that
because it was pretty with the weirdest
concerts I ever went to was probably the
most recent time I saw Kanye West at the
garden because with all this stuff and
all this planning making sure the crowds
in the right space I went to see Kanye
the show was at like 8 o'clock he didn't
take the stage until 11:30 what no
opener I mean literally
what's entertaining you for those two
hours there was this weird
ambient music that was playing like the
inside of a bad haunted house for two
hours for two hours I was he - he says
tours late no I just didn't start until
then that's when the thing started
hey but for most of the time half the
arena was sitting there on lines for
merch like the lines for merch were
insane people were waiting on line for
an hour and then he finally takes the
stage he plays for 90 minutes and he
leaves and you're just like that that's
it that's it I'm go home then I guess
we're we're done here throughout merch
holy holy [ __ ] there was one show
because a lot of them were in the winter
I was one shot they were in Texas and it
was still warm out there was a line had
to be a city block long at the long city
block and I go what are they all doing
and it was the the merch guys I raised
from Scotland or whoever is from he's
like what Jim I'm in Nice days I set up
the mood
sign I probably get more probably about
ad to 300 at least before they even
enter any arena well what they would
I've never seen anyone buy so much
merchandise ever it was insane yeah
how much merch Metallica fans buy how
would you travel other so you're going
with those guys I'm not with them
personally no no you're on the egg bus
correct yes
some I'm with the text I'm with the
lighting guy I'm with the the accountant
I'm with how when you fly want to fly
you're on your own they fly you airplane
okay that's make sense yeah I'm more I'm
more of a glider helicopter guy like
rocket packs
here's Rexxar tank Jim you would fly
like right like for instance we play
Nashville they give you the option do
you want to fly in a day or two early we
put you up so they fly the whole staff
in a day too early from wherever you
come from and then the bus leaves the
night of the show you get on your bus
you drive to the next gig 5:00 6:00 in
the morning you're there if they hand
your key you go to your room you're off
all day and the next day the bus is
waiting at noon bringing the arena
anyway tell you in the same hotel as
Emma no no they would they would base
themselves out of one city and jet in
and jet out every night okay Wow
yeah Wow they'd show up like the
president's showing up yes you start
seeing all the security you see there is
an intensity like oh [ __ ] they must be
showing up so was there ever any part of
you that was like you know I mean if
that's kind of how the talents coming in
maybe I should also be jetting in and
out like fatty
to be honest I was fine to serve rice if
I had let say we'd all fly together they
would fly together yeah they fly to you
like the first leg was all the northeast
so they stayed in New York so New York
they'd fly to Albany fly back to fly to
I think they drove to Philadelphia came
back they everything would jet in jet
out I'm gonna [ __ ] way that's kind of
crazy though because there's a chance
you're gonna miss something at this bad
weather but it's every other day it's
every other day so if they felt
something was bad and they would
constantly monitor it they fly in a day
early and then they'd stay in town but
very rarely were they in that town oh
okay
yeah and yet and and then I realized I
was I was a hot chick I would fly into a
city I flew into El Paso where or yeah
El Paso be effective and when I got
there there was this whole family of
like really nice Mexicans I like it Jim
you know it's good see we waiting for
you look please I'm autograph oh yeah it
was a little awkward coming off I very
rarely get that yeah and then they
follow me to the soil so you flying with
the band like now oh you know so where
they staying
that's my son he's a leper do you ever
wanna fly with them now no I mean want
to I'm sure you want it but not in the
sense that this is like really gonna
happen yeah you know I don't think it's
uh I don't think there's anything really
going on that plane yeah I really just
think they're all doing their own thing
they're all just like us they're on
their iPads or their phone they're
checking whatever and this one's talking
us why this one's checking Instagram
large going what's what was the last
setlist we did for this city and you
know I don't know I really I've decided
okay Jim Breuer but what i what i
denying oh yeah right right yeah the
live
and let laughs - or begin September 13s
for Jim Breuer you're starting at the
Paramount where you've had your
residency going on and then go into
Arizona and Branson and Missouri and
Pennsylvania and all over the place
official Jim Breuer comm is the website
to go to for all the dates so is reading
in an interview you have the residency
at the Paramount yeah you also have a
residency at the at the Bergen Bergen
PAC Bergen PAC Englewood yeah hey you
dudes great kick you do different
material every single time so what would
the residency how often are you playing
Paramount's pretty much up until May of
this year was once a month mm-hmm and
now doing like one every other month hmm
and Engel woods every other month but
you and you're doing new stuff every
single time yeah I don't I don't I don't
know what happened to me I've reached I
and I think it's the Paramount it's I've
never I have to write everything out and
I have to I've well structured bit like
it starts here and it goes on a journey
and then there's a callback in uh I just
reached a point where I just started
freewheeling mm-hmm and don't ask me how
I've done it but it's been pretty much a
different show every single show and you
know with the cuff a lot yeah a lot Wow
you'll do some material the same so if
you receive twice you might see 20 the
same minutes and 40 different yeah maybe
even a little more different wow that's
amazing that's [ __ ] amazing and are
you taping if now in the beginning of
the film every show that's smart man
yeah film every single show for many
reasons a because of that reason yeah
it's very frustrating
every time I filmed a special it was a
well-oiled or try to be a well-oiled
machine but a lot of times I'm best when
I'm not the wet when I'm relaxed and I
can go off on it someone said something
over here
and then I do 20 minutes on what this
banana said and then it turns into a
whole thing and then I come back and
then we go in a completely different
direction and I go damn why didn't I
have that filmed why didn't I have that
recorded now I do it every single show
so I got a stockpile of stuff that I
could just keep keep rehashing and keep
releasing you watch this stuff or no I'm
bad at watching [ __ ] yeah I I should I
record every show on my phone and I was
on a roll where I was listening and I
felt the material was blasting cuz I
would I would here just a little bit I
went oh I got it I could do 20 minutes
on just that that subject should be
needed out but I have to get back to I
haven't done it yeah it's hard you know
and if it's like work I know yeah it's
bad
I mean you're literally not only
figuring out how to tell jokes for a
living but how to do it without even
really traveling well what if I just
take my the venues near my place and I
just played those where my bus people
once a month yeah well what's blew me
away is the Paramount after a while you
know I have a VIP where you can have
dinner there's only ten people out in
there and a table what their dinner with
you or just have dinner with me okay go
in there we say hello and it's all
catered and we talk and a lot of times
it's baseball as doesn't matter whatever
it is very rarely very rarely do I get
those so when you start a comedy never
get that it's usually people just kind
of nervous and they can't believe
they're sitting in there and when I
started hearing I said so you from Long
Island no we came in from San Diego what
San Diego so what do you visit in New
York like what are you seeing in New
York like no we came out here for you
know what with you so you have your own
black ticket crew I it's a little it
throws me off a little oh well you're
never in Wisconsin so we came to fly
that I've had a lot of people fly in
it's weird to me I get the same thing
where they'll say where can we keep we
do we flew in to see I'm like really
like yeah
a wedding tomorrow that's not why you're
fluent I happen to be here don't say
that right now I went there has to be
another reason you have to be on my
hopes up New York City or something but
does it feel good after you get done
with that everything you're doing with
Metallica and be like wow this is what
it's like to have this kind of fan base
to then go and remember oh wait I have
this crazy fan base that's super loyal
that's traveling to see me that's coming
out to these shows every single time I'm
here I feel like I got a huge
responsibility to them yeah I got I
don't I turned a corner while ago where
I went I just want to be funny and know
this is really funny guy now I feel my
fans really emotionally attached somehow
whether I I don't know if I'm saying it
the right way but I I feel I have a
responsibility to always just crush it
for them and deliver for them and they
they honestly keep me going where I I
don't know I have a personal thing with
them if that if that makes sense yeah
yeah before I didn't really know them
I'm just like oh I'm sold out this is
great right we're now like wow these
people and and I gotta say the meet and
greets throw me what throw me off
because it's these are for blue-collar
guys here's here's a family and they
brought their 13-year old and their
nine-year-old and their grandmother
oh that's completely different Krupa
these guys are clearly thugs mm-hmm and
then this guy's a little off
he's a guy i got signatures from this
guy showing you his autograph book yeah
yeah index card he's really intense and
yeah and yet I feel flattered I'm in his
group cuz then he starts showing you the
people he has like wow you Wow could you
sign vertically I like my [ __ ] OCD
about that dump book I've always wanted
to throw one of those things into a
campfire Oh
and then there's a lot of them that are
that are heavy like there's yeah
vacuuming yeah that too I got a lot of
fat what a lot of fat people yeah a lot
of stuffs heavy a lot of it's a heavy
set people that lost people and Oh
heaven can relate yeah and I've been
getting a lot of that really and I just
lost so and so and I had to come see you
Wow that's where the responsibility
kicks in yeah I realize I was right
actually here for your emotional support
and that's just trying to avoid working
and I don't underestimate that yeah just
the opposite I figured this is not gonna
be a great show that wake it's gonna
look like a circus do you feel a similar
responsibility to Jim Norton fan who
wants him to have fun yeah I always
wanted to be good show like but yeah
just because they're paying to see you
yeah I never want I go I never want to
show to suck and I always try to do a
good show it's like I never I don't mail
it in onstage I try to be funny yeah
you always do you try it's like you kids
again there's spending money to see you
and I feel like I'm shocked in there I'm
always shocked at yeah so am i after all
this Dylan shot yes dice is the funniest
guy ever I would saw him on Anthony's
show we're walking down the street so my
people coming up for photos and dice
doesn't give a [ __ ] and he's never given
up but we're walking and some guy asked
for a picture and dices and I now we
were talking about something and we're
walking by and he goes I just don't care
he's like I'm like you don't care if
that guy's a fan he goes I don't care I
want him to go home and take my old
stuff and throw it in the garbage dozen
murders on stage though he's like that's
what I do in murder on stage I don't
want anything after that's the next next
next level that you guys will get yeah
we're like right now you're still in the
appreciation phase you know you you
don't care about the industry you're
here because you appreciate what you've
gotten your fans he's a different guy
those nice a different guy yes yeah
he killed I love him comedians love dice
yes love him yeah because he's the
purest form of all of us like even
though I'm I love the fans I talk to
them I wish i
the belief in myself to go no and keep
walking and I hope they throw my [ __ ]
out fuck'em right he's always he's
always made me laugh
like just offstage there's one thing
make any laugh onstage just who he is
it'd be very silly he's so silly well
it's probably I mean part of it has to
be Poobah I'll call it a Doughboy and
he's the worst to eat with cuz he
instructs you how to eat yeah I want you
to enjoy it nod the Russian dressing
over there I want to eat it but to do of
course you're following oh yeah
well yeah I guess it's like you go into
comedy desperately looking for approval
but all you want to do is not need
approval so when you see somebody like
dice it just doesn't need it and he's
still doing well in comedy you're like
that's there's temeka
there it is yeah he really is free yeah
Jimmy
you um see other comics most younger
ones I don't mean younger by age guys
I've been around and you watch them you
see how hard they're trying and then I
I'll look at that go oh my god that's me
or that was me you know don't want that
you know yes and I I do I see guys that
are like I'll see a guy like Sam rail or
Andrew Schultz these guys are so go yeah
yeah yeah yeah and I'm like much better
than you when you were young I'm
probably better looking too let's be
honest I'm guessing both larger genitals
men yeah but I know I say to myself
those guys are doing it I was I I worked
that hard for 25 years so it's like
right I actually learned from those guys
that when it comes to the newer stuff
they're doing like I see Andrew or Sam
I'm like you know what that's a good way
to do it so I called Android he's give
me all these helpful ideas and things
social media stuff that type of [ __ ] you
doing so learn from those guys too
you're better at it than I am but don't
you think that they're looking at you
and going hopefully in whatever it is 15
years I'll be on Jim's level in some
ways yes in some ways no like you know
I'd love to be in Jim's level which is
what but I'm the decline for 12 years
I'm sure that I think that's how you see
I know these are most people
they it's not like I'm trying to do it
the way as good as they do I'm not gonna
be as Pro prolific as Andrew Schultz on
so but it's like you can still take
little pieces of what they're doing and
make your [ __ ] better like it do but to
look at those guys didn't ignore them
how does it apply anymore yeah how can I
do that and do it better without looking
like I'm trying to be 30 because I'm not
30 right you're not no I mean I look
good but yeah so no I watch those guys
I'm like I kind of like I like being
around guys like that because it makes
you it makes me feel like I'm lazy if
I'm not doing something I have to be
doing something when you watch guys who
are doing this [ __ ] every day and
they're finding new ways to get fans and
it's like man I can't just [ __ ] hope
the people show up I got to do something
I saw Andrew a couple years ago on a on
a festival tour in Europe and I never
saw him before and I just so when this
guy's I just watched alright this this
kid is there's something about him I
don't know what it is and he was just
sitting on the thing and he would he
would get in groove just absolutely
crush and then he getting crews or
people like talking about he didn't care
and just pushing up a goal and I'd
always kind of kept my eye on him and
then I've seen him pop up now and yeah
yeah he's really going he is four he's
got he pushes the envelope there he is
agile on stage very comfortable very
best thing that ever happened to Andrew
Schultz was he felt like the industry
started ignoring him so he just stopped
caring and just started pushing all of
his stuff out there himself and not
trying to impress anybody except himself
at his own audience what happened to me
right couple years ago like all right
the industry doesn't like me I'm not I'm
not an industry guy I'm not a holly it's
over and that's fine I'm gonna live by
my means and then once you once it did
that I've had the best time my whole
life so years ago right like after I
said now half-baked when that that era
are you exhausted when you're like
trying to impress the industry like what
is this what is halfway what does it
roll into what is this turn
God why would he what do you say it
feels just impossible oh my god just the
thought of of the exhaustion of trying
so hard and just just running down every
alleyway like this is the alleyway you
know he hears echo of just me stepping
in puddles meeting I took a meeting this
was supposed to be the way to go
constantly exhausted
that's the exhausting part if they're
trying and you don't even know what
you're trying to do oh no what do you do
you're just trying to be somebody else's
vision of something and that's all you
do it I hate like what your voice just
to be funny
yeah my want your what are you trying to
say you figured out your brand yet do
you just watch over work though like no
I used to I get a lot of auditions like
I'll just do it in my fallen and I don't
get them but you be I mean you could do
it from home you're just gonna [ __ ]
closet and talking to a [ __ ] your
phone do you know here's where I'm at
Jim I'm not doing auditions I'm not
driving to New York City no you're doing
your phone and [ __ ] take and send it
through email you don't have to drive
anywhere I don't even I don't have an
agency for that so when the time comes
I'm sure after this tour and maybe to
Thai I just plan on touring until the
Don Rickles way and if things come my
way they come my way I'd start writing
for the first time in years and I love
it right what if those things come along
great but I'm not chasing them would you
do auditions on the phone like oh yeah
yeah that's how you do most 85 or 960
all my view auditions in the last five
years of it on the phone and if I could
do them on the phone like you get you
into a quiet space you talk if you once
or twice and you're finished
you hit [ __ ] sand and you email in
your audition and get done and you're
done
so you're just in the space now where
the only stuff that you were it is about
is what you have control over yes and
everything else it's ignored ignored
yeah I'd really have no
desire for anything that's not within my
reach right I realized a while ago I
swing it pitches low and inside and
maybe a little high and outside
everything else I'm just watching go
ball my problem is I let the strikes go
by and I throw my bat at the outside
versus every bad decision
[ __ ] yeah ball four still swing I
still laugh at things you said you would
I don't know whatever actors would come
on here and you go I just don't know
where to put my hands yeah what I'm
acting is stupid I'm the same way it's
not like there's a lot of guys who are
great at both but you know being funny
as a Stamper on the radio has always
been more I'd rather just Raman be us if
I had to go back I don't want to do
comedy I want to do I want to do drama
or dramedy I don't want to be a I think
that's been pronounced always what I
wanted to do but I was always push like
you're gonna be the you got every agent
like you're gonna be a really funny bug
I don't wanna write I wanna I can't
believe you know my voice operation
you're so good at that
well thank you naturally you should be
amazed really yeah I do what one minute
if I was with Jim I've been doing
voiceovers I would have had my third
one-man show by now call Jim do a woman
we should have been crushing as a
business you'd be perfect Oh one-man
show yeah easy
yeah carrot isn't natural I tried a
couple of times I don't know what
exactly beginning to end I've gone all
over the place why cause it there's this
and this is it just the father years is
just I could probably do four different
teams right if I wanted to we get a
residency you could do like six one-man
shows and every single
[Laughter]
one more gemandsam catch up with full
episodes and interviews from celebrity
guests anytime on demand using the
SiriusXM avid